you auditioned for Wes Craven for the
screen stuff yeah very quiet yeah I
worked with him too yeah did the scenes
and then he was like
that was good did you know all your
lines inside out no that's what's great
bro you can look at my audition tape I'm
holding the script I'm looking down I'm
improvising do you remember when
directors like Wes why they're the
greatest because they play it was an
audition it was play and he saw like
yeah he saw in essence it was getting it
losing it getting it losing it getting
it losing it Wes loved me the producers
love me the studio wanted a name I
wasn't a name back and forth back and
forth and then Wes God Rest his soul you
know he said this is my guy